[Music]
when did the drinks arrive
let's start with Phil saying that's
perfect all right buddy again our buddy
Phil Hanley is in the building
one of our best beds yeah I am this is
the only this is the first time I've
ever been excited to do a podcast
oh I do yeah yeah I mean they're fun
when you get there but I'm injured my
back and alcohol helps yeah and I
generally can't drink this early so I'm
excited how'd you injure it's been fine
for like six years or something like
that and I flew four times last week and
then my back was like a little funky and
then I stretched the [ __ ] out of it and
it's like yeah wait do you stretch it or
you get a a helper I normally well like
pre-pandemic I'd like work out and
stretch and do all that [ __ ] and then I
haven't been and uh while this guy's
going to town on these guys he's a pro
man yeah and you're a Negroni guy like
when I think negro I think Phil yeah
it's my favorite beverage you're either
drinking a scotch or in the ground yeah
yeah
he either drinks a glenfiddick on the
Rocks McAllen no McDonald's I like
Michaela okay do you oh yeah people buy
me Macallan sometimes because they don't
know the difference but yeah it's oh
thank you so much oh thank you beard you
look at that that looks good dude well
done with the twist yeah love the twist
oh yours is submerged I think that's the
move well I like to put it on the side
and then you can drop it in if you like
I mean that that's a smell right there
yeah I like giving the offer you know
yeah oh
that smells perfect Holy Ghost too yeah
those are those are mine just I think
it's a Pew for a second that's what I
heard what is that a great one those are
great too don't worry
wow this is I mean something about a
Negroni in the summer Just Hits perfect
wow that's great man look at that color
too perfect redness not too thick that's
too thin yeah cheers
[Music]
and for the folks at home I think that
just the one secret to like really
upgrading your Negroni game or your
Manhattans in general is to get a nice
sweet vermouth that's what I have in my
fridge I really like using corpana
Antica this is like the one that you'll
find the most
sorry we were raising our classy level
for a second with him explaining
vermouth yeah Mark just brought us right
back down
lifestyle you know but yeah it's good if
you want to up your game go grab it it's
the easiest to find and the best
this is the thing
from you vermouth in the fridge right
and people don't know that yes you
refrigerate your information yeah yes
yeah okay it can last for a little while
outside but after a while it'll go Funky
Music transitioning back into like uh
foodie mode yeah
yeah because after a while outside it'll
smell like watermark's farts so keep it
in the fridge great note what's in a
what's invert what is vermouth great
question vermouth is like a super super
uh like concentrated sweet wine ah I
never knew that okay all right that's
why like over time it turns a little
bitter but still keeps its uh sweetness
okay good cool just like a comedian yeah
absolutely yeah perfect yeah hey uh dude
yeah that's like hanley's go-to drink
man it's good it's good to have you here
you're like you're like one of the
first guess we want but you wanted to
wait till you had a yeah to promote
which is now available on YouTube yeah
how about that came out September 22nd
hell yeah yeah great special we were
both okay you were you killed it you
were there not I uh you were both there
and I remember being on stage in the
second show and being like oh this is I
feel like this is good because you know
nerve-wracking it is doing a special and
I was like I think this is you know I
think it's we got it and I looked over
and I could see uh you cracking up uh
yeah well you know what's great is we
always talk about this our friends were
all so busy which is good but we used to
see each other all the time watching
sets all the time always in the same
room and now we're always on the road
we're running around we're doing pods so
it's all fresh the material I've never
heard it so I get to just laugh and
enjoy it like an audience yeah it's
funny because it and the beauty of that
is the people that you respect most like
you got you'll see a set and I'll be
like oh [ __ ] I did so much old [ __ ]
tonight and you guys haven't seen it in
so long you're like oh I love that new
band you're like oh thanks like a year
and a half on the road like tight yes of
course yeah and then you think man I
suck but you realize this guy's been
doing that bit since 88. yeah yeah I got
busted from Sam uh last week because I I
was [ __ ] around for most of the set I
was trying new stuff and then I closed
with uh an older joke and I came off
Sam's like oh that was you know a great
set or whatever that was like you know
uh and I was like yeah I was kind of
[ __ ] around he goes didn't wasn't
that your clothes are from your special
[Laughter]
oh but it wasn't my closest
yeah I was just kind of trying some
stuff out I was like I think that was
too close
but he was just trying to get off stage
yeah I had to [ __ ] with him yeah but
yeah I mean that's the fun too is like
you know we're all on the road so much
that like you know we were at The Cellar
on a weekend together and it's like holy
[ __ ] that's how you kind of dream it up
when you're a kid yeah the three of us
yes hell yeah that never happens and I
will say my you two are my two first uh
comedian friends in New York City here
here I felt like Norman greeted me when
I got off the plane I tried yeah I like
to welcome yeah very welcoming and then
used to walk around that little paper
boy during the day oh yeah I forgot
about that I just chalked it up to
Canadian no and then Sam and I when I
first like moved moved here uh we lived
across the street from each other yeah
oh Williamsburg yeah we used to go to
the same coffee place you and I with a
special little coffee yeah it was so
good it was like our afternoon yeah we'd
walk over but I when I met so Norman was
so friendly when I first got to town but
Sam was like a love up for a sight thing
because we were playing that crazy show
remember that Show Low uh yeah
oh it's that powly mother yeah yeah it
was this it was like six people in the
crowd there was a huge screen and there
was like aerobics being yeah played in
the background yeah that's a good idea
no it'd be like a woman's ass right
where your face was very distressed you
know it was a post show thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it should be so [ __ ] distracting it
was 80s aerobics but anyways I remember
seeing Sam and I'd probably been in the
city for like a few months whatever and
seeing Sam and it was like holy [ __ ]
this guy's got bits yeah you had bits
well you still do but like back then it
was I was so blown away because it's so
rare you see so many Comics but so few
of them you're like holy [ __ ] yeah I
think there were like eight people in
that crowd too yeah and we bonded
because you were like I gotta do this
college and I I remember that a little
bit and yeah that was a weird show
because John powley who would run the
show he'd have the aerobics on the
background the show was called buns and
puns yeah he would walk around with
jello shots yeah crowd and cinnamon buns
it is yeah and it was a weird room it
was like it looked like uh the bar from
uh Clockwork Orange it was all white
yeah totally white everything's white
seating every person beat me with a
dildo that time
what happened to Polly he was a
character I I've seen him on the street
a couple of times really there were some
great stories about him I mean he had it
was uh
quirky character we used to hang with
John Powell I remember one time he was
in a bar and he noticed a guy was
pickpocketing people so he followed the
guy out of the ball he goes hey could
you come back here and the guy was like
I didn't do anything and he goes I'm
following you he chases the guy for like
10 blocks on the phone with the cops
what the cops get him just as a guy
tries to get away into the subway and he
got some sort of like badge of honor
type thing really because he brought the
guy in and all the guy all the wallets
were returned wow
yeah and he's not an intimidating no he
looks like a [ __ ] Flamingo yes he
might be the least intimidating for so
friendly though but I remember that show
he would just like he was barking but
he'd like a girl would walk by and he'd
like walk down the block and then like
turn they'd turn around and come back in
he'd pick her up yes yeah he had that
skill he was so uh agree with your word
I guess Fearless but he was like
non-threatening that's the one yeah oh
look at that what is this is that buns
and puns
how the hell did I get on there wow
Jonathan powley there he is in the top
left
oh yeah look at him yes
I haven't seen that in years it was
funny because you guys talk about the
show having eight people that was the
highlight of my month doing that I did
so many businesses there were some times
when it was like 150 people in a tiny
room and sometimes when it was like
12 people but yeah I mean yeah that was
my favorite and he would put us on like
whenever we wanted he spoiled all of us
he was really lucky for that so look I
see Becky Owen there every now and then
that was if Nick Vatterott would go on
there that was fun
different time we were we were
scrounging for shows I always think it's
crazy like we take for granted I
particularly take it for granted because
I grew up in the city but like you know
you came from another country you're
from Canada from Oshawa originally yeah
and you grew up later in life in
Vancouver yeah and then you move I mean
across another country it was uh yeah
and I had done like I remember
this is a and then I started all over
I'd done comedy maybe eight years I had
done uh the Craig Ferguson show which
like felt like a credit I was like New
York no one gave a [ __ ] because I didn't
get it from New York ah interesting I
remember when I uh someone vouched for
me I showed up it was an open mic at
three of Cups there was like five people
in the crowd I just moved I was I could
I hadn't lived here I was staying in
here I'd rent like an Airbnb for three
weeks and just try to like meet people
and do shows and I showed up this fight
is this terrible Open Mic everyone's
bombing and I go to the dude that's
booking it uh RG RG Daniels yeah yeah
and I go to him I'm like yeah uh you
know so and so wrecked me he said he
could do a spot he goes yeah send me a
tape oh my God this City's gonna be
[ __ ] brutal well yeah to immigrate
you're the only one that Sammy you're
the only one that recognizes I had to
get like two work two work visas and a
green card wow how's that process for
the folks I mean I mean I'm dyslexic so
any forms it's like this many yeah and
uh yeah my mom would help me but uh it's
[ __ ] it was probably in total probably
25 000 bucks yeah the three things and
as a struggling comic yeah yeah it was
uh get out of here yeah totally yeah it
was rough and then it took so long but
now obviously I'm so glad I did it but
God damn it was a pain in the end but
the dream was always like you never
flirted with LA no because I watched
right before I started I watched
comedian and Seinfeld was doing the
seller and hanging out in New York and I
was like oh [ __ ] like that just seemed
like the thing to do yeah that's the way
to go la would have been better because
it's so close to my family but uh no I
wanted to be yeah just New York seemed
like the place to be yeah you just New
York over your family
you want to be a good comedian New York
yeah you're such a New York Comic I mean
it's like you know your shit's so tight
and uh I remember that Ferguson said you
have one of my all-time favorite jokes
in that set because you say uh I quote
this joke all the time you say you know
when you you meet the right person you
know right away oh yeah going to meet
the wrong person it takes a year and a
half oh right yeah that's right that's
one of the shortest most perfect jokes
and it's such a there's a novel in that
joke because you just picture all the
bad relationships yeah yeah there's a
lot of research to come up with that
but it's funny I remember that was one
of the that was like probably the first
good joke I ever wrote I had that and I
had a twin a joke about I was dating a
twin at the time and I wrote them that
afternoon and that's comedy where it's
like then four years later you write
another one yeah I mean like I remember
they both came out the same afternoon I
was like this is it this is gonna be a
piece of cake and then you're just like
you know you write one of those and
you're like cool I need 75 more yeah
that's exactly it yeah and then you're
kind of scrounging and you're like milk
what's funny about milk you know you're
trying to write a joke and there's
nothing coming that's what we first
bonded about because I we both would
like try to write every day and I
remember you talking but you still like
Pace on your roof yes that was my big
move yeah because I couldn't write I
can't write a Starbucks these guys are
sitting on a Starbucks no that's crazy
to me I'm like I was look at everybody
absolutely or check my phone so I need
to pace so I don't look at the phone you
got the TV off but then I live with my
girlfriend so I couldn't write jokes in
front of her with a hairbrush going Uber
huh you know I got loud so I'd have to
go on the roof for private suck yeah
right right I'd like to [ __ ] other
people yeah
[Laughter]
sometimes to be on the roof and there's
some other guy on the roof like hey
what's he doing over here crazy guy
talking to himself to jump off yeah so
that that was tough you had to make it
work back then you had to figure it out
I was a janitor and I would write in the
boiler room that's incredible because I
didn't know where else to go
that's that's incredible you never had a
job here no I've never had a job ever
ever No I uh yeah I had a job for a
couple weeks in in high school and then
I worked in a like a couple bars briefly
bartend uh yeah I was a terrible
bartender I was a bartender in England
in a gay bar what are you a spy where'd
this come from bartender in England yeah
we were a model that's a job yeah that's
a job yeah but it's like yeah so no I
did have I did have uh jobs I was
bartender in in England and I got hired
because I was a model as a gay bar and
they made me like head bartender and I'd
never bartended before this is your [ __ ]
your sitcom by the way oh really oh yeah
come on model gay bartender yeah the
modeling thing didn't work out they're
like kid we got one last stop
yeah uh no it was when I first moved to
England before like I was just started
modeling and I worked in this gay bar I
was head bartender in the main bar and
it was such a mess it was brutal Yeah
Yeah Boy George would come in who Boy
George oh wow yeah so it was a gay bar
yeah yeah yeah oh okay oh man Yeah Boy
George can't go wrong there no well do
you really want to hurt me
was that was that a fun gig uh it was
yeah it was it was uh yeah it was fun it
was just wild I was I was like 20 or
something like that yeah yeah it was
like
the the Food Service whatever industry
is bananas I mean it's just blow and
hook up especially like get like the gay
scene in England at that time like I
thought I'm from like a like basically
like a mini Detroit and people [ __ ]
party hard we partied hard but then that
like England is just like next level I
don't know if they still party like that
but like yeah how about the modeling
uh yeah modeling yeah they that's a like
never did that start like how did you
just get into that well I had a friend
who she was like successful and I came
she lived in New York she moved at
Oshawa when she was like 16. she was
like you know very successful and then
she lived in New York and I came to
visit her and all my friends are going
to college I'm just like chicken was in
special I couldn't go to college and she
was just like brainstorming what I was
gonna do with my life because the
options weren't very there wasn't a lot
of options in Oshawa I applied to work
in the convenience store across the
street from my high school which would
have been [ __ ] depressing like a
7-Eleven yeah it was yeah it was called
One Stop but uh yeah it was could you
all the teachers who said you wouldn't
amount anything would be there buying a
sandwich and a coke yeah yeah being like
yeah I still got it
and uh so like my parents were like
tripped out that I was gonna get like
stuck in Oshawa and yeah then is it
funny that you're basically a writer
like you're you're dyslexic
you sold a book you write in comedy you
you write your own act I mean you're a
dyslexic writer it's so it's so yeah
everything I've done has always been the
biggest pain in the ass you could
[ __ ] possibly do including moving to
New York like it was like such a [ __ ]
pain but it's because
as of the first day grade one if you
can't read or write it's difficult yeah
you know so I was like whatever but um
yeah England was fun uh tons the people
did tons of drugs but I I did drugs in
high school so by the time I got to
England I was like kind of over it well
you you were an acid guy I took some
acid yeah
we could tell by the shirt yeah
obviously I took yeah but you know what
I took a lot of okay there's a great oh
there's here's a wreck I have so many
recommendations here's a wreck the other
one on uh Netflix it's a documentary
about uh Bob Weir the rhythm guitar
player for the Grateful Dead but he's
talking about the Grateful Dead would do
acid every Saturday afternoon damn and I
was watching it and I was like I used to
do it every Friday and Saturday like I
did it twice as much as today as the
dead yes Jesus man I always thought
there and I [ __ ] more than Will
Chamberlain
I heard
does that that sounds very unhealthy
yeah you would think it was a I think
and I don't recommend LSD for people
because it doesn't agree with everyone
some people take it and they're just
tripped out forever for some reason it
agreed with me and yeah you would do one
on Friday and then I would double it on
Saturday wow and uh did you even have
time to come down you'd come down a
little bit I'd come I was brutal I
wouldn't sleep all night because you're
up all night and then my dad would want
me to cut the grass yeah but
um the book cutting the grass it's pink
and [ __ ] you're pushing his unicorn my
dancing why is it Paisley uh but um but
sorry what was that oh then it's
Saturday you double down oh yeah it's
like LSD acid really agree with me
[Music]
[Laughter]
no but what I was going to say is I felt
really like dirty because I took drugs
in high school and I all my friends were
older and I felt like dirty for taking
so much acid because there was like it
was like a full pot at the time and then
I saw a therapist one that we're all
very familiar with sure and I told them
and he goes you took acid because you
were in special ed you were super
frustrated with school you felt
completely misunderstood and you needed
a break from reality and then like this
I was like yeah I had like it's the same
as when you have a shitty day and you're
like I want to drink I had such a shitty
day I just needed you know something a
little stronger than a drink right right
I love the idea of Phil being like 13
years old just hanging out with a bunch
of like 40 year olds I hang with an
older crowd yeah yeah
that makes total sense why you would do
that you were yeah you needed an escape
and you found one absolutely and then I
and then so I finished high school and
moved to England and started modeling
and stuff and then drugs were very
plentiful you know what I mean your
friend got you into modeling yeah the
friend from Oshawa moved to New York yep
she got you into she and she's a success
yeah she was successful she lived in New
York and stuff like that and at the time
New York the guys that were like models
were like all American guys that
actually looked like models and I had
super skinny and I was long hair and
that was can we get a picture of you
fellas
there's one there's one if you go on my
Instagram oh boy
very exciting uh you're a big cardigan
guy for a minute I did yeah I did okay
uh but um yes so then by the time and if
you're like a straight young dude
working at a gay bar the drug options
are very political but I was kind of
over it by them okay a lot of Clips
you're in for a treat Matt oh man follow
me keep scrolling keep scrolling oh now
he does you want to go down
you want to go way down this is like old
school uh-oh that's a good bar keep
right there yeah
it's way down sorry
damn dude
is that Jared Leto holy [ __ ] there's a
bit that photo's altered because it's a
it's a [ __ ] but that's without the
mouth moving you can look at that
straight straight black I like it better
with the lips moving
wow got a pretty mouth boy it does
holy hell holy [ __ ] this is wild look at
that look at that there dude that was my
first fashion show that was the first
big that was in Milan that was my first
like fashion show so when did you come
out as a straight guy
dad sit down
that's not what you think maybe it's
dead stand up yeah yeah and leave holy
hell but yeah great jawline good eyes I
got a comedy special in Canada way way
too early yeah they do that over there
oh they yeah they just they because it's
like funded by the government they have
to give a certain amount out holy [ __ ]
that's crazy to think of Comedy funny by
the government yeah yeah it's hold on I
want to see Haley give me just to top me
better baby I got shows tonight I got
shows too and we recorded another app
Phil we're gonna be [ __ ] up here you
have another episode after this I don't
know if you get one before you were here
because we're both on the road for a
while so we we backlogged a couple of
these bad boys what were you drinking in
the previous one paper plans oh okay
I've never had any app I mean dude make
them just make them one just so we can
have a sip just so we just so he knows
what he's missing I mean it's a Hidden
Gem really I think it might be my
favorite cocktail you've talked about
them I've just never I mean more than an
old-fashioned uh old-fashioned's like a
classic I like Manhattan's better than
old-fashioned I love a Negroni I love a
martini paper planes in that category
for me it should really it should be a
classic it's just not as simple as the
other ingredients I agree it should be
in the mix of like the Staples really oh
yeah is that good I was at a bar the
other night and they had it and I got
[ __ ] excited and it was like you're
damn right I'm getting one oh God when
you want to drink and then you're at a
bar it's just perfect and better when
they have when you have a weird taste
I was in Costa Rica last week yeah and
uh we did a show and the guy who ran the
show was like I'm taking everybody out
for a nice steak and the whole thing so
we go to this Costa Rican Steakhouse it
was amazing and I just gotta I said you
know it could be a dirty martini and it
was so [ __ ] good when you hit that
you get the exact thing you want and it
hits the spot so good and when someone
does it right it's like executed
properly yeah bikinis are you really got
to be careful because you don't realize
how [ __ ] strong they are yeah
dude I went on a date and I had
I want to say like you know four or five
geez
what they're serving them with a little
side thing oh yeah
so kill one I'm like oh I have a little
[ __ ] so I probably had like eight and
I'm like holy [ __ ] I woke up that next
morning puking my guts one of my
favorite quotes of uh from my dad was
when I was a teenager and he must have
we were gonna drink martinis and he must
have heard me planning it on the phone
or whatever because I was like saying
goodbye to him or whatever he put his
arm around and he goes you see my ear he
goes martinis or murder ah yeah and they
were they were they were [ __ ] deadly
someone kicked over the vodka and we
were just drinking vermouth all night
yeah that's a bad thing dude it's funny
as hell like that's like your like dark
still like like you're in the united
planning a heist like we murder him at
noon yeah we're gonna drink Martini's
your dad's like don't do it son yeah
yeah don't do it good advice
martinis are murdered but they are like
they [ __ ] you up
martinis like one is not enough he said
it's like tits yeah there we go it's
weird twos two three's too many and two
is perfect
uh yeah yeah no I feel like that I've
heard that with just drinking in general
I feel like four are pretty good you
like four tits
it's two women threesome yeah or like
that guy another type of mammal a
manatee
five martinis on a date you must have
been rolling I was on [ __ ] and Fuego
for the moment for the date I was
killing it the next morning I was just
like
oh yeah that's the worst puking up
nothing that's the worst when you're
just like I'm just here to puke but
nothing's coming out yeah I was looking
for uh I was looking for uh
for these pills I I used to have this
doctor that would just hook me up with
like anti-nausea prescription pills and
I couldn't find them so I'm like I'm
like on all fours like pale
I just tough it out I was able to fall
back I also have to sleep a certain way
because my neck is still [ __ ] up so
I'm like I can't sleep on my side I have
to kind of fall asleep in my back yeah
so I'm like it's hard for me you're
gonna die how many Jimi Hendrix style
yeah right terrible puke in your own
mouth yeah suffocate look at the go dude
oh good good mix just a smidge I just
want a smidge just give him a taste dude
rub some on your gums dude you want the
rest Peters oh [ __ ] oh he's a alcoholic
tell me this isn't a [ __ ] dope ass
cocktail the paper plan all right I like
the glass is that a traditional paper
plane glass usually you want it either
in like a smaller Coupe glass but we
just used all those and uh or you can do
what's called like a Nick and Nora glass
which is like one of those small that is
in Nick and Nora Charles
what's up from the Thin Man I guess I'm
not sure yeah I'm not sure but it's
basically it's like this it's like a but
a little smaller like a very small like
almost but it's like a short Stout flute
like a poor flute like a joke
there you go I love the little is that a
paper airplane on the side oh wow nice
touch the Deep Devil's in the detail
yeah I nailed it look at that
detective one of the uh that's a good
wreck if you haven't read it the Thin
Man a married couple you know he's a
retired detective they married uh
he married her so now he's like this
badass retired detective who's just
written or I always say like you want to
make a movie cool or a book cool just
make the character Rich because you can
do anything yeah so the character Batman
so he's just a rich cool badass and they
solve Mysteries together and get [ __ ]
wasted it's a fun they're fun I mean
it's uh by dashel Hammond who is a
Pinkerton who was an actual oh wow
detective really yeah badass and big
inspo for Raymond Chandler if you like I
feel like murder mysteries that are that
are fun books that uh and the movies
Thin Man movies are great too yeah dude
that drink is insane you like it I do
like it yeah paper plane we're trying to
bring it back I'll order one when I'm
out oh yeah you'll look cool you'll look
like you know your stuff love it yeah
they're getting really popular too so oh
yeah
I think we might have something to do
with it hopefully I might be drunk we're
bringing it back bringing it back just
like where's that clerks too uh I gotta
watch for you guys clerks too and Ari
shaffir already made this wreck I'm on
our podcast but I'm going to double
wreck it everything everywhere all at
once the movie I gotta see oh I got I
gotta see it we're the only people
visually it's like unlike anything
you'll ever see I've never heard one bad
review about this movie the one thing I
will say it's a little long for what it
is because it's just like fast paced
like Bam Bam Bam for like two hours 12
minutes but it's it's gorgeous it looks
I would say if anyone ever seen like
Kung Fu Hustle like the Stephen show
movies like the same thing okay okay
it's a comedy it's weird as hell is this
a comedy yeah but it's like a heartfelt
comedy it's the kid from Goonies uh
grown up data really and Short Round
also from Indiana Jones that's right let
me show you Jamie Lee Curtis thank you
yeah Jenny slate that was one of my
early comedy crushes was she do you
remember that show she used to do it
where they would line up out the [ __ ]
yes yes that show is hot with the
dangling the white yeah tampon strings
or whatever those were yeah that was a
hot show
I saw Chris Rock there once really yeah
yeah how was that I saw Zach Goffin I
kissed her before really yeah well he
was there with a Z's I think he was
watching Aziz do something and then they
were like you gotta go on he was like
[ __ ] it I'll go on and then he tried a
bunch of [ __ ] that scared the hell out
of him and he left because that crowd
was a little uh precious so precious
soft exactly he's too good for them now
let me ask you this there acid you like
the acid I'm a I don't touch ass what I
did in college it was too intense I go
all shroom oh where you at on the the
mush I like uh I mean I don't do
hallucinogenics anymore but uh
uh like I mean I would be open to down
the road someday but I yeah for me we
just couldn't get the mushrooms like I
remember like thinking as a teenager
like oh mushrooms like it seems so
exotic and cool
um so we rarely had them but it's a
similar feeling I feel like uh I feel
like acid is liquor and mushrooms are
beer yes you know I was gonna say that
acid is is like mushrooms is like a dull
saber and no acids like a sharp one yeah
well to be asked it was just like whoa
holy [ __ ] my brain is exploding I'm
seeing and thinking too much where
mushrooms are like hey I'm laughing I'm
giggling they're so similar though they
are very similar same thing no micro
dose ever you don't do this uh I did
briefly during the pandemic but I don't
really do it anymore what brought that
on just you uh just sheer boredom yeah
uh I remember I was going I remember I
was micro dosing I was going through I
was going through a breakup and I was
like super bummed and then I saw we were
hanging out or something like that you
go like you seem like so much better
today and in my head I was like yeah
cause I'm flying on acid ah really yeah
can you function uh yeah I just took I
shouldn't say I was flying but I was a
little like I like micro dosed times two
times wow but I did feel better during
the breakup but yeah I don't I don't
know now I'm just like whatever I have a
coffee I had a friend in high school
that's the most I grew up I think of all
time I used to do as I'm like no just
I'll have coffee all right
I used to trip balls now I do an
espresso
it's a great commercial for this
President yeah right all right take it
easy beard you thank you thank you oh
thanks man thank you brother thank you
Danny swoops out he's like a drunk
Batman
so uh I had a friend in high school he
got into a fist fight he was kind of a
nerdy guy got beat up whatever
we were hanging out like a month later
he's on acid he's flying he's through
the roof on acid eyeballs huge chugging
booze being crazy climbing up trees and
[ __ ] we see the same guy who beat him up
but he was like a jock he was like a
tough guy and he goes right up to him
beats the [ __ ] out of him no way he was
on acid he was Juiced up he had no fear
whoa and just the intimidation he had
the crazy eyes and he was like a foot
short on this guy he was like a football
guy and my friend was like this you know
nerdy skateboard dude kind of Scruffy
and he beat the [ __ ] out of him do drugs
at no he just walks up to him with a
skateboard
yeah we're like dude don't do it he
[ __ ] you up so badly he remember he
punched him and he uh pierced his lip
through the the tooth like the two came
through unless that [ __ ] happens here
you're probably Fearless I guess once
you get your ass kicked like that you're
just like we we grew up in similar
situations because you talk about seeing
people get the [ __ ] kicked out of them
two yeah there would just be like they
would look like they had that disease
that The Elephant Man had afterwards oh
yeah swollen they'd have like like it
looked like half of a tennis ball knots
yeah it was so brutal brutal I saw guys
get kicked in the face when they were
down you know with a Doc Martin just
boom to the face like a soccer kick
you're like terrific yeah oh my God I
don't know what that was oh that's
horrible yeah that's bad yeah yeah great
ad for Wilson though
Wilson the tennis balls
yeah you know uh yeah dude I mean that's
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of you like
that I I knew I had a friend like that
who would do that and he really and see
New York is fearless he was like one of
those dudes who didn't look tough but
every time he fought it was like game
over it was I know they're like
something something possessed them yes
in that moment he was the most gentle
guy he beat me up once we were both
drunk and I made the mistake mouthing
off to him and it's hilarious and he
just took my face I think I swung at him
and missed he took my face and just
smashed it on the [ __ ] floor oh
bloody nose everywhere [ __ ] and he just
[ __ ] and that was kind of it I mean
it was like he just kind of kicked me a
couple times I was like I'm done oh my
God when he got in it with other guys
that's when it was like he sent one guy
to the [ __ ] ER yeah no with the you
know just [ __ ]
I get a [ __ ] and he didn't look like
he can fight those are the scariest of
course but he's such an athletic thing
the coordination and the like it's
insane I know that it was it was an
adrenaline like it was just like ah it
was like what it was more like what's
going on at home yeah it is quite really
athletic yeah there's just so much anger
maybe the dad hit you or you know death
in the family or you're gay or there's
something in you that's like ah I've
been holding this in I'm angry I grew up
with a guy who had taken he was like the
toughest guy in uh Oshawa and you could
even you could that's almost like an
insult oh it's the toughest guy in
Oshawa if you wanted to you could you he
didn't even have to he was so tough he
had such a reputation that you didn't
even need he didn't even need to be
there you could just remind someone you
were friends with him and they would
they would leave you alone right right
it's like yeah able yeah and but he
wasn't he was like a [ __ ] athlete he
was a great hockey player yeah
Taekwondo oh geez yeah and so he was he
was graceful and a badass dude it was
crazy he would do like round like it was
like Karate Kid [ __ ] yeah in a street
fight he would do like round houses and
wild crazy have you seen the new Karate
Kid on Netflix Cobra cut I loved it I
watched the whole thing it's like dude
it's so dumb it's so I mean it's fun but
have you seen it Phil I saw the first
season yeah it's a kid's show it's a kid
show yeah but I tried to watch the
newest season and it's just like all
these arcs of like kids like flirting
and they're like they're in like eighth
grade they're like I mean I can't watch
this [ __ ] [ __ ] pedo yeah and then and
then I love how the whole Arc of that
show is like uh like remember what
happened in ninth grade I'm like no 50
year old talking
no 50 year old has just hung up on a
karate tournament right it's like it's
part of the fun that's funny Williams
incredible he's the guy who plays Johnny
Lawrence
guy he's incredible it's such a bummer
some it's it's the acting's like that
where he just he didn't have he just
nailed it so hard in the original Karate
Kid then he didn't do anything since
then right he had a couple bully movies
back to school back he was typed oh
right yeah because he was the bully he
was the blonde bully in the 80s damn
he's a good actor but he also is so good
at being like the vulnerable guy like
this is a three-dimensional character
like it's funny how that character is so
uh likable and Ralph Macchio's character
you're like [ __ ] this hand job this guy
like you got a hot wife you got a big
thriving business yeah and you're just
[ __ ] with this dude who lives in like
a motel six yeah [ __ ] you that's oh yeah
he's worked look at that he's you know
the same oh really maybe I'm wrong do
you remember what don't you feel like it
was like 20 years where you didn't see
him in anything oh definitely you know
the same guy who wrote uh Cobra Kai
wrote Harold and Kumar he worked a lot
Harold and Kumar is great really great
bombed at the theater yeah and then it
bombed it bombed really and it was like
a huge thing where everybody's like okay
we'll make it was a big stretch to make
it like everybody's like we'll take a
shot on this [ __ ] weird movie that's
a great comedy it's great but it killed
in DVDs raunchy I think that's what
happened with Austin Powers too I think
it killed him and rentals yeah I don't
know I think that was in the that was
pretty full of [ __ ] here I don't know
Harold and Kumar uh Big Lebowski was
like that for sure God he worked a ton I
just didn't see any of these movies well
first of all I don't know if any of
these are
getting out there some of these might be
direct to video let's be honest
let's scroll over let's see some of
these he got like uh nominated for an uh
uh an Oscar for writing a short film
really yeah that's what it said in the
oh wow all right that's a great moment
in in a
comedians
goes Stephen right what has he done
lately
for an Oscar no he won oh he won one
roster what else yeah what else yeah
attacked me when he's got an Emmy did
you hear orney on what the [ __ ] I listen
no uh Sam was listening to you the other
night it's a wild one really well he
just reveals a lot the tension is so
real between them yeah Mark Maron I love
him but God damn is he like if he if he
pill he's easier to he was nicer to us I
feel like Marcus we're like of a
different generation yeah with him yep
holy [ __ ] oh yeah he comes hard at you
what I was just like hey I never liked
you yeah why you're like he'll open with
this yeah I don't know God damn he's
such a great interviewer he's good he's
might be the best yeah he's like you
know
he's incredible and those I want Marin
on this pods he would trash us and we'd
and we'd do something we'll get like Jew
food for him we won't do it that's what
we did with you in Nicorette
with the root beer floats we put alcohol
on ours we didn't you know but yeah we
won't do alcohol if you don't want to
drink you don't have to drink on here I
can see him sitting there going like so
you guys have to drink to be interested
I don't need alcohol to be funny oh I
got it okay oh you guys drink your like
Bros your Alpha I got it all right
thanks Mark yeah good thanks for coming
not Alpha at all I would have been were
you guys nervous before doing WTF oh for
sure yeah I'd be thinking about it the
day before I think but it was also I did
it like at the height of like the very
beginning of covid where they're like
you're gonna do it in person I'm like
yeah it's Marin I'll do it in bird but
like yeah but it was one of those things
where I was like uh
the world's [ __ ] over anyway yeah
that was at that point I was like but
yeah I was I respect him a lot I grew up
respecting marriage yeah like his house
I listen to his albums as a kid you know
yeah but and Obama sat in that chair
exactly and you go in and he makes [ __ ]
at ease because you you go on his house
and he's like ah my cat [ __ ] on the
carpet and you're like oh okay and he's
in shorts and sandals and so it really
comes down a peg it's not so
intimidating and he's making a tuna fish
sandwich he's like oh we're recording
five minutes let me take a [ __ ] and he
makes a coffee so it's actually kind of
loose yeah but this [ __ ] yeah yeah
took a loose [ __ ] it [ __ ] helps a lot
I was like dude that's a loose turd he's
like [ __ ] do you how do you ever go
to La I feel like you're not you don't
make that track no I don't make that
track you got to make that I should in a
while I when yeah now that the specials
that you can yeah that trip anything
that is hap anything I've ever Sam gives
me the advice and if I do it it hell it
is like a game changer so yeah I'll go
to La yeah
but like go enough just to get on the on
the pods and I had this CD or like I
recorded an album wasn't gonna put it I
wasn't happy with it Samus knew what
he's like put it out and just like did
changed everything I was able to like
not have roommates there you go 100
thanks to Sam why wouldn't you put it
out
destructive [ __ ] I guess yeah I was
like I don't like my Cadence like it was
like I don't know it was weird I just
didn't I wasn't happy with it but it
like no one played with their [ __ ] I
guess and also you start doing Clips
which took a minute a 100 Sam is like
well you're so good at crowd work like
Phil is one of the best crowd ones yes
and that's a great joke writer too but
he really is like it is some people
they're doing crowd working like
whatever Phil is genuinely there's
people like you know Todd Barry Phil
like there's certain people you like
enjoy watching yeah do crowd work you
know well thank you Phil's so [ __ ]
good at it he does his own style where
he kind of negative yeah audience yeah
it's like it's a a unique way to go into
it oh yeah for sure but Sam had been
telling me for years just post crowd
work Clips because no one doesn't like
them and I never did and I just didn't
do it and then I've started I started
posting Clips like every other day and
like it's a world of difference yeah
this is like in the last month wow yeah
it took 10 years
but it's just such a difference really
Phil values my advice a lot I did it I
did it uh 14 days ago
no he gives great advice yeah well it's
just a different game like we let oh
I'll be funny I'll write jokes yeah get
crowds to laugh at me but that's like a
drop in the bucket now being funny is
like seven percent it's so I know I mean
not really it's like 80 but you know
what I mean it's like it's yeah it's you
got to do all the other [ __ ] and I just
hated I hated I hate it I pay people to
do it it's such a pain in the ass you
pay people to cut the clips though
because how do you trust that they would
well they go hey is this good and they
said it to me and I go out put that joke
back in take that one out whatever and
then they re-cut it but yeah it's a
little scary but at this point I was
like put it up I don't care yeah you
start to lose Faith after a while
because it's so much work it's so much
work you can't live a normal life you
need to stay relatable as a comic and
you need to like do [ __ ] you need to
live a life and when you get this caught
up on like phones and social media and
stuff you're not going out and doing
things in a person and being a person is
part of what makes the material
relatable of course yeah because like in
New York being it's not a normal
activity to do a spot at the cellar than
hang with comedians for two hours then
you know go home watch two hours where
the TV and go to bed at four get up at
noon like you know what I mean that's a
it's a great life oh yeah
but you know now we were talking about
recently like Clips are so important now
that I'll have an opener who's like okay
at comedy but he's like oh I'll cut
Clips I'll film the whole weekend I'm
like you're in oh God yeah and that's
how it is now no yeah also the people
that do the Clips in the test subtitling
they are [ __ ] they just disappear
into the night that is like the ultimate
Vagabond okay you have someone you're
like this is great yeah and then like
three weeks later you're like oh yeah I
don't know I don't shine shoes no more
yeah exactly the postcard from like
India
now you're like that guy yeah yeah holy
[ __ ] but these young Comics now they
know how to edit I'm like how do you
know how to edit it like I learned it
man I'm freaking out I don't know what
to do to make it in this business so
they know Final Cut Pro and Avid they
take all these classes the smart thing
to do if you're like if you want a
little side gig as a comic it's it's you
know you get extra work you will you
know you used to just be having a
license you'd get opening I know that
was the car the clips of the new car
yeah Clips are the new car okay yeah
you're right having a car back in the
day it was huge that was when they say
Carr was the beginning of career car
yeah that was some quote only when I
started let's see why I didn't catch up
not my quote but yeah
but dude I mean I'm pumped for you you
know this special I think is Really
Gonna Pop I think so such a good special
and it's like oh thanks it's like you
know jokes it's jokes yeah it's hard
jokes you film with the seller shout out
Liz we love you Liz yeah Liz is the best
manager the seller the comedy seller the
best club in the world I'm hot and cold
on her but uh no we're gonna clip that
part out I it's like Liz manages the
seller and then she also like somewhat
manages my life she's another really oh
God she helps me with so much [ __ ] it's
crazy I'll see we live in the same
neighborhood me and Liz and I'll see her
walking a dog and I'm like what are you
up to she's like I gotta walk the dog
then I'm gonna turn the lights on to The
Cellar the kitchen is fighting with each
other and then I'm gonna go feed
Michelle Wolf's cats and then I got
eight shows tonight I'm like who are you
it's so great I mean you see her working
like tonight at like 2 A.M she'll be at
a table like
Spritz in the glasses yeah yeah yeah and
and the best thing is that like she took
a three-day vacation which she never
takes good for her and I swear to God I
had just given her [ __ ] I was like three
days off like I you know I was a teaser
someone walked up to her like where have
you been
like I should never taken even one day a
week off and you take a three day
vacation for the first time all year and
everyone's like where were you like
that's your yeah hard laptops on the
beach and [ __ ] too 24 hours a day she
gets text she manages all the show how
many shows are at the cellar a week like
yeah or some of that she manages all the
shows all the comics yep which you know
we're all a mess yes then all the staff
all the bar backs all the [ __ ] sound
right the waiters the bouncers yes I'm
sure Phil's like what is spin cycle
which one do I put in is it colors and
whites she's like Jesus right then then
uh all the crowds right it's insane how
many people go in through the seller a
week I saw her I don't know if I should
say this this is how badass Liz is here
we go and we'll move on after this
because uh she's gonna hate this but
although also you never see Liz go like
uh I'm just I'm overwhelmed she keeps it
all in and just keeps working she's a
[ __ ] her friend raised that she just
is it'll be fine she always says yes
that's her Mantra she's her Mantra she
says to me all the time interesting yeah
she said it depend I was like the
pandemic what are we gonna do is comedy
ocean it'll be fun and that was in like
2020. two things she said that's what
they said in the 911 flight
to these days to me is it'll be fine and
Phil no one cares oh no one cares kind
of a profound yes no weird way like hey
it's all meaningless anyways I got my
[ __ ] life last night and I got home
and I got it to go and I it said Phil no
one cares oh that's sweet yeah she needs
a hug she's the best somebody hug Liz
for Christ's sake and give her a
pounding I remember it's a good railing
let's be honest God damn it Mark
we uh were there one night and this
woman was being really rude to her to
like you know the show was sold out you
have to get there at 8 30 for a 9 pm
show everyone knows that you get their
30 minutes early to get seated when the
person got there at like 9 10 and
they're like you gave our seats away and
Liz was like you know the rules is this
I'm so she's being very nice yeah he
just gave him away yeah like
non-stop just berating her at a certain
point I I couldn't stand as I went over
I was like Liz we just had like a couple
of feet to open up you should give it to
him two seats just opened up and she
looked at me like smiling and she goes
the seeds open up I was like no they
didn't you stink yeah
[Music]
I'm just like at least like the person
walked away fuming and Liz was like I
hate you so [ __ ] much but that was
pretty funny you yeah uh your
interactions with her are the best the
Yelp reviews on the seller are not
pretty because it's the best club in the
cut but they don't there there's no
nonsense they mean business so like
you're late they get rid of your seed if
you talk they throw you out they can't
yeah you can kind of get away with it
but that's why it's the best like
exactly because they don't [ __ ] run if
you show up drunk 20 minutes late for a
show some people are gonna some club's
gonna let you in because they want the
ticket price sure sure but you know that
person's gonna suck exactly 20 minutes
late and you're bombed and they're not
hurting the product uh groups in like
you know that right yeah you can't have
more than what four or six people or
something something like that that's a
great thing
you didn't wait an hour in line
chardelia we're gonna name a chardelia
Patrick Murphy's the next one start too
I mean they just I knew they were better
beer was cold what a [ __ ] horrible
thing cold beer who likes cold beer the
beer was cold the comics were amazing
staff was very rude and quick yeah quiet
be quiet you down uh Patrick noisy son
of a [ __ ] Patrick you're a dumb [ __ ]
comedy's a two-way street one star again
I knew these reviews were bad I never
even looked at these it is the best club
on the planet is it the best club on the
on Earth it is but that's why these
reviews don't matter guess what if you
don't like how you're treated it's
they're probably better to us yeah
what's that good point they're probably
better than us you're getting better
Comics yeah your Comics are great it's
the it's the best club and it's all I
mean the people if someone give them red
Red Review it's the same person that is
told totally all one stop I'm telling
you man if you haven't already it's
smooth oh if you haven't heard already
it's smooth sex summer the leading the
leader in below the belt grooming is
making sure here we all have a ball this
summer by giving your pants
Partners everything they need to stay
fresh I love this thing you gotta love
the
manscape performance package 4.0 it's
got it all I use this thing on my sack I
go around the base of the shaft you just
want a little extra length and no better
equipment than these guys manscape did
it right they got a goddamn headlight on
the thing yeah and uh yeah you can't
Nick you can't cut I mean there's a lot
of veins down there and a lot of uh
precious material you don't want to ruin
I just use it man it's it's I feel
lighter it's great yeah it works I had a
[ __ ] fro covering my balls yeah big
fan our pubes look like our hair so uh
it's not that different and you need a
real I got sideburns too I need a real
mower down there the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer and weed whacker knows and ear
hair trimmer features proprietary
Advanced Skin safe technology to perfect
protect your delicate parts and holes
both are waterproof so you can shave in
the shower come on get it all out in one
go manscape even threw in two free gifts
to their perform orange pack is 4.0 the
manscape boxers and shed travel bag take
a look at the shears 2.0 a luxury nail
crewing kit grooming kit I keep one of
my my bag all the time this kit includes
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with those feet get 20
off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscaped.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code drunk
at manscape.com it's smooth sex summer
boys get on board or get left behind
with your hairy ball back
I've seen them throw people out all day
long because it's the same people that
are like we were only laughing exactly
like [ __ ] face you were not only
laughing yeah I was laughing there's
puke on your shoes yeah
I was puke laughing
uh so one time I saw a giant comic on
stage I'm not gonna say his name hugely
successful big famous comic and he was
hammered and he's up there like man I'll
tell you another thing and one guy was
in the crowd like what this sucks you
know what what the hell's going on
because it wasn't great I'll be honest
and and the comic saw this guy doing
that he's like what's your problem and
he was like I'm just saying your Hammer
this is weird and he's like you think
you're better than me and it was it was
ugly well eventually they threw that guy
out they threw the guy out in the crowd
and the guys in the in the wings like
why are you throwing me up what did I do
the show sucks and they were like what
games they just shoot him in the head
you got to get out of here and he's like
wait what they're like shivering him out
of there he's like what the [ __ ] did I
do and I was talking to Liz she's like
he's got to go put back the guy's taking
a [ __ ] on stage yeah exactly he's doing
heroin I was like this smells bad to
like kill her too
but that's how much they love the comics
that they're like throw him out because
we'd probably have this drunk celebrity
on stage and it was pretty good it was
the right move yeah yeah it was like Liz
was a mob boss she's like him can't get
rid of him chill out of the cats the
seller's the best club in the world man
the best club on the planet the best
I have a show there every Tuesday at 10
30. thank you
after this oh I'm pumped to drunkenly
bomb some new material oh I got my spots
until like midnight my agent just texted
me we're coming tonight I'm like great
I've had uh five drinks
well it should go well it's usually my
crowd and their uh oh wait you're here
tonight I'm doing the oh never mind
doing a longer set with Will so Vince
will host he'll do time I'll do like 30
of new and I don't have an hour yet so
I'll just bring them back up and we'll
[ __ ] around oh that's perfect but but
he's he's great at that I love will yeah
he's the best with the crowd work and
the riffing uh it's remarkable you have
a new 30 minutes it's not good it's
gonna be an ugly 30 my friend it's gonna
be [ __ ] terrible still that's that's
probably list has a new 45 yeah
a month ago really my special's been out
for a few months oh has it a few months
I don't know but but early to have
no but he's like he's he's getting in
the stories more okay and so he's
putting together like an eight minute
story here so seven minute story there
and it adds up I was just texting saying
I'm not saying I was walking home from
the club I was like I need a story just
to have a five minute chunk you gotta
make some worse decisions my friend
that's where they come from all my
[ __ ] best stories
they come from me getting lit on the
road yeah yeah and I'm like there we go
it's true yeah Drake it helps with
comedy drinking is healthy I think so
yeah for art Bodega cat spirits.com
I got to admit I had I did not have high
hopes for her
you love it it's so [ __ ] good that's
good and I'm not even a I'm not a ride
drink you know whiskey or Scotch but
yeah why is underrated yeah everyone's I
was on the bourbon train everyone's on
the Scottish train getting the [ __ ]
ride all these celebrities they're
starting they're starting whiskeys and
they're all doing tequila and I'm like
yeah yeah stay over there yeah let us
have the Rye yep Uh Kevin Hart is a
tequila I'm like you'd even drink get
out of here
come on let us have you have everything
else Kevin Hart you got Jumanji nine
unless unless you want to come on here
Kevin yes we'd love to have you we'll
get you a booster seat and the whole
thing
I brought my I brought Kevin Hart up
once at the cellar like I was they were
just like bring up Kevin Hart you know
not even to the host to me I was on
stage yeah and I was like all right
thanks a lot I'm Kevin Hart you know I
did my thing yeah my dump thing and then
I was like you guys ready for a treat
Kevin Hart and I thought he'd be like
why'd you say you're Kevin Hart but he
didn't even hear it oh really yeah I was
waiting for like a fun little there's
literally if you got a call from a date
and he's like 40 million cool yeah what
do you say yeah yeah hold on Spielberg I
gotta go on but he was fun he's a nice
guy great guy Nice Guy funny guy I met
him once and he was [ __ ] awesome
great guy just very cool super nice I
was standing beside him right basically
where that photo was taken and uh he was
saying he was about to go on he was
doing new stuff and he turned to me goes
yeah the car's picking me up like for
set tomorrow at like 6 30. and it was
like 1 30 or 2 in the morning wow and
he's working new stuff like apps into a
set he's a good thing he was laughing
I was doing the uh what's that Mohegan
Sun I was in the comedy club and there's
an arena there he was at the arena I was
at the Mohegan Sun comedy club and I
went to the gym I made it to the gym at
like 11 A.M he was already in there just
alone just going at it wow working out I
leave I see him I don't bother him he's
working out of the gym I leave at like
noon you know gamble little whatever
start drinking and hang out [ __ ] a
hooker go to the buffet I walked back to
the pool I was like yeah maybe I'll take
a dip and the pool is connected to the
gym and this is like four still in the
gym no Kevin Hart are you serious I
think he maybe does like two sets even
still so I mean insane he was still
there insane so he is just that guy he's
a he's a warrior he doesn't stop he is
fit oh yeah he's ripped
huge dong apparently really 10 inch yeah
that's what Patrice would say really
yeah Robinson too Keith too Keith
Robinson dude Keith his new material is
so funny he's great have you seen him
Keith Robinson has a new bit so Keith is
a great comic who mentored uh Kevin Hart
and a lot of a lot of Philly guys yeah
but Keith has you know he said his
second stroke and he's a new bit about
how like he's a new bit about how he
someone forgets he's disabled and will
catch himself laughing at other disabled
people
that's a great I may just look at him
like yeah you too he's like all right
[ __ ] oh that's brilliant it's [ __ ]
great you want to talk about having a
new hour he just had a second stroke and
has a new hour he's doing hours at the
at the cellar he's like working I love
Keithville genius he might be one of the
coolest dudes in my life the funniest
yeah funniest coolest the best ball
buster best on the planet because he
does it he actually loves everybody yeah
it comes from love Yeah and his laugh is
so [ __ ] funny if you hit him back he
laughs it's not mean it's supposed to be
like Play yeah you go I go or whatever
but it's just great he's a classic but
he came he tells stories about like the
old school yeah when like Patrice and
everyone would bust balls and he he told
me a story but like cruising in with a
new sweater and he's standing in the
doorway he's standing in the doorway and
someone yelled from the table like made
fun of like he knew like okay I'm like
you know this is a risk yeah and he said
he just remembers you just turn around
and leave because you couldn't spend the
whole night you know what I mean yeah of
course of course it's so different now
right now if you followed me on stage
the other night and they were bad they
were really bad and I got off I was like
dude they're really bad and he goes
we'll see like cocky yeah and he went up
and he goes they were really bad I
didn't believe you we followed each
other he followed me like three straight
shows and after every show he'd be like
you better not [ __ ] me again I put it on
you that's great so yeah he's so good
and a lot of people try to do what he
does but they don't have this he's
special because he has some warmth to
him he'll laugh at you these other guys
are like they're just cocky and mean
yeah he's cocky mean but he's got heart
and he likes you it's an art absolutely
perfected it he's cocky mean but also
he's busting your balls and he's got
that thing where he's so revered yes
that it's an honor that he's even like
focusing on you of course of course I
remember when I was brand new with the
seller he was trashing me all night one
night and Gary Goldman drove me home one
night and Gary in the car uh I said is
it weird how much he shits at me and he
was like are you kidding me I'd kill for
him
he was jealous that he was [ __ ] on
me that night it's like Rickles you want
him to trash you want it and another
thing about Keith how you were how Sam
was saying earlier that you gotta like
live a life or whatever Keith has life
experience oh my God it's just the depth
that's why he's so great yeah I love him
we got to get him on here yeah yeah he's
got it he's got some stories he's got
like 12 baby mamas he's got nine kids
it's great it's fun stuff
I'm trying to make him more
well he's got a I think he's got one kid
he's got some stories
I I peppered my own interpretation like
that he's got he's got some fun stories
baby mamas there's only nine kids he's
got uh like the lady throwing the shirts
out of the windows store
he's got crazy stories plus he like
Sammy said he like [ __ ] mentored
everyone oh yeah oh yeah and I think we
need a little of that I I don't want
Comics to be mean I don't want people to
other people's feelings blah blah blah
but there needs to be a little put in
check in comedy yes we were missing that
and also the one who does it with warmth
it's not not in a way like I'm gonna
hurt you it's way like I'm gonna [ __ ]
I'm gonna T like dude I've had Bodega
cat I was Liz bought a bodega cat at the
cellar the other night and the second
Keith heard it he was like oh you and
Mark Norman whiskey Colin Quinn starts
[ __ ] on me there you go even Ryan
Hamilton you know you don't expect to be
the guy to [ __ ] on you Ryan goes oh I'm
with a name like Bodega cat you know
it's gonna have widespread appeal
everyone's trashing us like I'm furious
I'm furious you guys I'm making a
whiskey but then of course at the end of
the night I'm texting Norman about he's
like but you're glad they're saying it
to our face yes there's nothing worse
than leaving and being like you could
get a load of these jerk-offs they're a
great idea then you leave
yeah I mean if this wasn't being
recorded we could name 10 comics that
don't get it to their face of course
that's the ultimate insult oh that's the
does that means yeah yeah exactly you're
not really a comic nothing worse than
someone being nice to you oh yeah
absolutely incense yeah well that's what
you know like oh I love your haircut you
know like women do that then they walk
away and like she's [ __ ] lesbian
she'll never get laid or whatever the
hell you know you want them baby mamas
yeah
the name of this up
um but uh yeah that's from okay going
back to watching the comedian and moving
to New York that's what [ __ ] blows my
mind is like tonight shooting the [ __ ]
with Colin Quinn I know who's cooler no
one is cool we still think of like you
know that's the thing it's like we're
still comedy nerds so it's like crazy
that we know David telling Colin Quinn
insane like you know call me at like 3
A.M last night it was one of those calls
where I get like he just texts me at 3am
and I'm like I'm up yeah and it's like
it's like a you up tax which to check
and call yes and we're just shooting the
[ __ ] and I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm on the
phone with David tell he's like the
greatest comic ever I know crazy I
talked to him today and my lady walked
in the room and I'm like this
yeah yeah yeah
I didn't want to I was like in the zone
I was talking to David tell so I didn't
want to like have any distractions yeah
she was like what was that what were you
talking to I was like David tell she's
like oh okay I get why you're behind the
couch you know you didn't watch your
sounds yeah I was naked it's hard but I
had to just I had to be present with
David tell oh yeah 100 you don't want to
be on the sidewalk like hold on Dave
there's a guy walking by you know
almost
no yeah yeah was he asking you if
someone had a bit like that no he was
asking about some clubs he's doing and
he's like a club in Louisville and I
said Norman's just played there so so he
called me and uh I'm playing there I
wasn't ready for it so I was like oh
that's yeah you won on the corner you
want to be ready for that oh yeah it was
out of the blue but we we did like 30
minutes on call and I got a couple
laughs and that's all you want he's the
best I had a call like that and then you
I don't even know if you knew that I was
is on the phone huh it was like two
Sundays ago I was visiting uh a video I
was visiting someone and out Upstate
yeah
[Laughter]
podcast is getting more and more cryptic
yeah
[Applause]
yeah whichever one I love you baby
I was scantily clad just you know had
you know whatever post coitus is
something like that okay and uh the
phone rings it's like an LA number and
like you pull the butt plug out of your
ass yeah not yet no so I pick up the
phone it's Bert and he's recording a
podcast and he's asking me yes he's and
I'm like yes and he's asking me about
watches and we're talking about watches
or whatever and then he's like oh [ __ ]
and then so we're talking and then
Whitney phoned you yeah and uh I
realized how much better you are at
podcasting than me because they asked
you about shoplifting or something and
like at a drop of a hat I was like I
answered and was like oh hey oh what's
up like it took me a minute to figure
out it was being recorded or whatever
Norman was like off to the right he's
like ah you're gonna kill me yeah
you're on the phone well I we were
wrapping my segment up I had no to this
day I think it was being recorded I I
don't I'm sure he knows I'm sure it was
I fully I didn't know but for a minute I
thought they were just asking me like a
watch question yeah and then but it was
funny because he's like oh I think
Whitney's calling Norman and within two
seconds you were off like talking about
shoplifting well I figured if they're
calling me it's gonna be recorded I
didn't know who it just came up a blank
and I'm like yeah yeah this business is
so silly I know that person calls me
it's gonna be for everyone yeah exactly
what it means that's crazy that's crazy
the world we're like we're in but yeah
it's a lot of pressure I'm seeing him
soon I'm excited to see him who Bert
what are you seeing Bert pod oh you're
doing the LA pod yeah oh dude it's at
his house wait till you see his house
really uh dude he lives next to uh
are you supposed to be saying this uh
probably not he lives next to Henry
Winkler bleep that out but famous
dyslexic yeah
yeah dyslexic I think yeah
from Brooklyn I think yeah Legend check
that I think he's a Brooklyn guy but
either way his house it's it's
everything you want in a house he's got
a giant gym in the back and a shed
really does he know that
yeah the gym had a lot of dust on it but
uh oh Manhattan that was close Okay I
heard he's the nicest guy same thing
yeah everybody says he's the best yeah
he's so good on Barry God dang he's good
in Barry Barry's a great shirt yeah
Barry's good 76. uh so yeah Bert's how
he's got the fire pit he's got the pool
he's got the hot tub he's got the back
deck with the barbecue pit he's got a
podcast Studio he's got the man cave
he's got a home theater it's insane wow
incredible home yeah you know all you
see is like La uh in the news and it's
like homeless and fires and you know
shootings and then you go to Bert's
house you're like I get it I get why
people live here the weather's perfect
I'm in the hot up with a high life you
know just living it up that's the thing
about being super rich like yeah things
are going to be okay wherever you are I
know I know exactly maybe in Saudi
Arabia you got money you're like things
are good yeah I don't know I'm looking
around yeah it's pretty cool and then he
was in I got there early and he was
shooting up Podcast with Mike Birbiglia
so then Mike birbigley and Bert walk out
of this garage and you're like where am
I this is yeah that's crazy yeah fun fun
Showbiz it's fun Showbiz baby Showbiz
baby then Bobby Lee showed up and we did
an episode
love it man good times what any uh any
wrecks Phil oh good question oh and I
haven't done my pet peeves oh
yeah they're bit
whatever you got oh yeah
um
what I recommend uh one thing and you
listen to it and you loved it I
recommend and you'd get a kick out of it
too I think
lay it on me uh the queen country album
whoa
it's so good I like Wayne so we feel
pushes this hard I'm like I gotta give
it a go it's damn good wean so wean I
believe the story was that we owed like
one extra uh record on some contract and
they were like wanted to like we'll show
you this could be untrue but okay we'll
show you and they went I do know they
went to Nashville and they recorded this
album with the Jordan airs which were
Elvis's backup band wow Japanese Cowboy
so they do they it's a country album and
each tune is a different type of country
like there's like that like 70s like
trucker like driving an 18-wheeler over
the Town Line Country then like a
country ballad right and uh
yeah and the lyrics are hilarious is
[ __ ] great so I recommend the wean
country album but also listen to the
[ __ ] Grateful Dead listen to American
Beauty yeah listen to working man's dead
yeah then go live with Europe 72. and
then treat yourself to like spring 90.
okay boy and this guy nobody knows more
about the Dead uh I I know if the first
civilian I know I know a lot yeah well
what do you think about the the Garcia
band oh [ __ ] I love the guns I love them
too but I feel weird I'm like is this
not the dead the dead but they're part
of the Dead Jerry Garcia band I mean it
is it feels very spiritual if people
like heads call it like church music
yeah and you know what's great about the
dead is they give you hope as an artist
quote unquote I hate saying that but
they never hit it big really but their
tour everywhere they're sold out
everywhere they go hit it big no well
they start they started in 65 and they
built their following by basically they
did what Comics do now by telling fans
to follow them they sent out one of
their albums said uh dead dead freaks
unite who are you where are you and
people would send in postcards and then
they would mail out information about
the tourism they let all their fans they
had a section in the stadium where you
could tape all the shows so once they
played it the music was the fans so
there's over 2 000 shows you can listen
to and uh they started in 65 their first
hit was in like whenever Touch of Gray
came out 87. yeah it wasn't even yes so
that was number one either and that's
what 22 years in yes and that but that's
what where the problem was because then
they became super super popular but in
the 90s they were like the most popular
they'd sell out Soldiers Field like two
nights in a row wow yeah well there you
go you see if it's good it's good it
doesn't have to be commercially
successful look at that beautiful man
with a smile yeah and Jerry was just
like to see him perform was oh you saw
him yeah when I was a kid yes it was
unlike anything
what was so special about it he just had
a thing and there are people that put it
more exactly than I do or and like you
know like famous musicians whatever he
just had this this thing you can't put
your finger on it was just such a great
performer and everyone would focus on
him and everyone would follow each note
and he would do things I remember once I
had my eyes closed and I said to uh I
was with like an older like friend of
the family so I was like what just
because the Crowd Goes Crazy sure look
what just happened they go Jerry lifted
his leg people were so focused on him
yeah
um yeah he was just such he was just
such an incredible performer but if yeah
if you listen to Jerry Garcia band you
kind of get an idea of because he's got
the backup singers and he just he like a
comic he just worked he toured with the
dead and then he would want to go back
on the road and he'd immediately tour
with
um Jerry Garcia band yeah but it that's
like it feels like it's got like a
gospel like spiritual Total Community
yes yeah it's a Love Fest
he he died it's really sad so when he
went into uh rehab and he died that
night in rehab of uh OD heart failure or
Heart Like heart attack heart failure
but he also he did you know he did
partake in narcotics but he also he
didn't have a very uh healthy diet sure
sure he's a big dude yeah damn yeah but
uh so I recommend starting because
people always like where to start with
the dead I'd say American Beauty I'm
gonna get I'm gonna do it yeah I mean
it's just great and then uh working
man's dead and then if you want to delve
into live then Europe 72 and then just
go crazy maybe a little spring 90. yeah
the music's So I listened to it when I
write a lot I love what a Grateful Dead
kind of mix yeah and it goes all over to
the Garcia band Grateful Dead yeah other
[ __ ] later but
I I write all all the time on it but
then when that one [ __ ] song uh the
Clarice what is Charisse uh uh Reuben
Sharif yes deep cut I'm impressed oh
really yes that song is so beautiful you
have to stop writing and just listen to
it I have a story about Reuben oh please
so Reuben and Charisse was a Jerry
Garcia Bantu the dead did play it like a
couple times in the 1991 and you hear
the live if you put Ruben and Charice
live dead 91 you hear the crowd because
they knew it was a Jerry Garcia band for
the dead to play it the crowd just goes
[ __ ] Bonkers it's my favorite song of
theirs dude it's amazing but uh he
cheats on his Reuben cheats on Charisse
and I met a woman one night we were in
Vancouver we were partying and there's
this girl named Charisse and we were
partying and we're hanging out and
um at the end of the night where like
everyone's saying goodbye and I said I
go I love your name I go it's the name
of uh my favorite Grateful Dead Charice
and she started crying and she goes I
know but the Reuben cheats on Charice
I'm like he doesn't cheat on her he
doesn't cheat on her and then years
later I found out yeah I listened to the
lyrics over again I'm like okay
but she was quite uplifted when she
found out
she was a I thought she was the girl in
the song no no no she was just she was
just a woman that I guess her parents
were deadheads and they named her after
oh okay damn yeah but that's a great
tune great too it's a beautiful love
song yeah he does I think he does uh uh
cheat with someone from the audience
oh there you go remove the comic and uh
yeah wow yeah and they're so like they
they I mean this guy does not look like
a rock star but he just is I love that
too they all were like that they never
gave in to any trans I mean Jerry's
there I'm sure wearing uh black track
pants yep yep and they all look totally
different Bruce hornsby's in the house
for the early 90s yeah it's like Dave
Attell it's just about the art it's not
about the look or how cool I am or the
celebrity yeah look at Phil Lesh you
look like a shop teacher yeah exactly
exactly
oh is this it
oh okay yeah they only played this tune
a few times because it was a Jerry tune
oh yeah and then of course Scarlet
Begonias and all the other big Touch of
Grays are great but this is a deep deep
really well I mean not for Jerry band
but for the dead yeah all right this is
my favorite by far what I like to do is
I just put in a show in YouTube and I
just Lo like I just I don't look at the
thing I just have it playing in the you
can put in anything like we'll go MSG
and just you know like they would used
to play eight nights at MSG so do you
dig fish and all that or is it no I
never got any fish I never did either
but again talk about following yeah they
saw at the Garden four times they sold
at the Garden 13 times before they did
this like Baker's Dozen unbelievable
yeah
um no I don't know I just I just like
the dead I never really got into fish I
I understand why people like it yeah but
and I think if I yeah I just I don't
know I just had this thing for the dead
since I was a kid because Bob Weir was
dyslexic and when I found out when I was
a kid I just oh liked it about that yeah
there you go there you go yeah he was an
acid guy Bill will they all were yeah
well there you go all right good wreck
good right you see the passion I mean I
love it people have told me you got to
do a dead pod
me yeah yeah I've tinkered with it I
it's like car I yeah I don't know yeah
I've thought of it if so it's a wealth
of information
yeah it's yeah it's basically all I like
to talk about
we should give a shout out to uh Marcus
price yeah he did the special yes yep
did a great job great guy Marcus Russell
price on Instagram and stuff yeah yeah I
can't wait to see the finished product
but I mean uh I mean I was there it was
it was killer so uh he's definitely big
big now he does like our [ __ ] Schumer
[ __ ] your [ __ ] Pete Davidson John
Mulaney Aziz he's like Hannibal he's
everywhere it's basically if you see a
great comedy photo a live photo chances
are he took it up someone these days he
does everybody oh yeah
all right and uh you should we do bits
or is that crazy uh yeah let's do a bit
why is that crazy I don't know I don't
know how long we're going or whatever
yeah you feel well you got something uh
uh I have a I okay so this is a bit so
can we just do premises yeah that's what
we prefer un uncooked Half Baked this is
[ __ ] I've tried to put this in the
oven so many [ __ ] times uh let's just
go and you both know it should not be a
Jew
person Sam has heard this a million
times I'll probably talk to you about it
you Norman okay but I have it the
premise is that hooking up with an X is
the closest we can come to time travel
I love this already I promise yeah but
it will not is it just for people that
sleep with their exes no I think you
just need the perfect time travel
cliche I you know what dude it's I've
spent like after the movie Back to the
Future but instead of like a old guy
with white hair it's a woman who just
knows a few new sex positions right
right oh yeah yeah I don't know like
I like depressed I tried like the angle
of like going back to the future but
like because you've had sex with a bunch
of other people all of a sudden you know
you know like a bunch of old moves yeah
showing up in the like 80s with an iPod
like it's like it's funny person away I
cannot get the audience on board yeah
and I've tinkered with it for a long
time yeah right that is a tough one and
I've Googled it is like a time machine
it really is yeah but you can't perfect
it I've tinkered I and I've like Googled
like
excuse me time travel cliches and all
that [ __ ] yeah it's hard maybe the
problem is that back to the future is so
is the kind of the ultimate time travel
movie sure and it's so old that a
reference from Back to the Future oh
yeah it doesn't fly anymore time travel
time travel they know there's also that
other thing of like you know they say
you go back in time you step on one twig
and it changes the course of the Earth
or whatever yeah like I've tried that
like about like pregnancy like wearing a
condom and all that stuff yeah it is
wild though hooking up with an X is
a Monumental event yeah because it is
kind of like time travel you're like
should I be doing this yeah am I gonna
[ __ ] up something in the future yeah
right you know like uh right
damn am I [ __ ] up the balance
yeah the balance exactly it's tough
because it needs to be simplified he's
at one perfect angle because it's a good
premise but it's loose yeah oh it's
loose
like people always say I would kill Baby
Hitler be like I would [ __ ] Sharon one
more time yeah oh yeah yeah she had a
baby I'd kill that one too
something like that uh
damn that's good oh yeah what's the
cause remember David tell had that bit
about uh you ever want to go back and
[ __ ] somebody you [ __ ] 20 years ago to
show them how much better you are at it
okay yes yes Classic Hotel classic yeah
made it past your thigh uh
not even maybe ah [ __ ] yeah I don't know
that's a tough one it is tough let me
noodle on it noodle baby
I almost want to pull up like a pull out
a Jules Verne book and and leaf through
it for some ideas yeah I want to Google
juice Vern uh he wrote The Time Machine
oh really yeah there's a book called The
Time Machine oh yeah really was that H.G
Wells HG Wells that's H.G Wells sorry
Jules Verne wrote uh
20 000 Leagues Under the Sea I actually
don't know oh boy he's a writer what did
he write
oh boy
okay he wrote that
Journey didn't you write Journey to the
Center There It Is Well played what uh
yes Around the World in 80 Days yeah I
don't know time travel uh
-huh
ah [ __ ] yeah it's a tough one going back
in time I think we're looking too hard I
think it's a simple yeah it's never not
for it's never for free
it always comes with a consequence
You're Gonna Hurt the future yeah in
some way that's why you wear it because
you step in a leave you're like no I
[ __ ] her like like it's like uh now
you're like oh [ __ ] space time continuum
maybe you know what you always learn
kind of in these time travel movies that
the future is kind of like accepting the
present is better than the past maybe
the angle is you're like hey man turns
out that wasn't a good idea you know
what I mean future is Bleak yeah yeah
but don't I think maybe the problem is
there hasn't been a big time travel
movie recently that would help
um
what about inception isn't that is that
time travel that's like time bending ah
[ __ ] okay it's like in dreams and stuff
can you relate to that when you yeah you
sleep in the next it does it feels like
all of a sudden Everything feels like
you're back it was 10 years ago years
ago yeah you go right back to it that's
why it's I love the pro it's so
relatable yeah you're laying in her bed
again the smells her bed the smells the
feet like even I swear to God your
genitals have a memory man yes yes I go
here we go the inside jokes are the same
yeah I'm thinking of a memory foam joke
uh with the mattress I watched pitched a
memory foam joke to you and is the only
time you [ __ ] let me hide it ah well
there's a lot of those yeah I didn't
know I hadn't been going to open mics in
a long time and I went yeah it was done
to death I learned a valuable lesson
yeah is it hot in here or am I gay it
feels warm maybe it's the flannel that's
the flannel yeah up sweat all right yeah
dude I'm telling you this something
memory foam confrontation
all right what do you got all right so
this one I might have pitched by you
guys I can't crack it there's something
here okay I haven't said this on the Pod
have I about the Elon Musk joke have I
about how like I say what he's got like
eight kids and I said what I think
unites the ultra rich and the ultra poor
is that they will come in anything
that's my premise they will come they'll
both come in anything I think it's like
the ultra richer like yeah I'm rich
it'll work out and poor people are like
I mean I'm [ __ ] anyway you know I
can't afford one kid I'll just have 12.
it's so true that's like the ultra like
luxury and also like yeah I'm [ __ ]
let's have some fun let me nut inside
this person and I could afford eight
kids and what's the difference anyway if
I have eight kids right that's kind of
the angle yeah I don't really know where
to go there's a mom in a trailer with
eight kids running around she's on
welfare she can't afford it for a mom
with eight trailers yeah and Elon Musk
is like I got eight kids I'll just go
tomorrow I believe he's got eight kids
yeah yeah he might have more I mean I
think Nick Cannon has more than that by
the way he's got a lot of kids damn yeah
that's funny
you don't want to be a middle class
person with eight kids well yeah they're
like I have some things I could lose
yeah yeah oh wow that's just a hard
eight right there
boom what about Nick Cannes he's got
nine nine wow that is wild that's child
abuse if he asked me yeah I guess he can
afford it oh he's got eight one day I
think he has nine all right let's get
one die yeah he got rid of one baby
number nine
all right I like the kid's name is Zen
we don't think about you
the ninth baby's name was oops Yeah
uh uh oops cannon that's not bad I'm
scared
um that's the oh never mind all right
[ __ ] I'll figure it out yeah it's
funny we're fried oh we're fried we've
been drinking all day
we're bad at comedy poorest and the
richest for the intersect yeah maybe
yeah that's like the only thing they
have in common yes yes
um you don't know what it's like you
know the poor people are mad at Elon
Musk you don't know what it's like to be
uh to be broke like us you rich piece of
[ __ ] and he's like well we have the same
amount of kids you know right right or
you do the same thing to commiserate or
to celebrate
and it's just you're the same yeah yeah
we're like ejaculating and they're both
apparently against abortion you know
they're both like no that's wrong
because elon's all about over he's like
we got to populate really and then we
just like [ __ ] he's all about we need
to populate also he's like we got to get
to Mars yeah yeah
that's true he wants to populate and
leave which one is it yeah
interesting what do you got ah mine
sucks you guys the years are like you
guys both have like a rich idea
go anywhere crack them yeah I got a
couple of those but I'll try out any a a
quick one
so you know I think like most kids when
I was younger I'm talking real young I
wanted to be black you want to be black
it's cool they're cooler whatever yeah
and so I grew up in a predominantly
black neighborhood I went to public
school so if you got called the n-word
it was exciting so I wonder if there's
people transitioning who like a guy
transitioning into a woman and
somebody's like ah you [ __ ] they're like
I made it you know because I'm a woman
you're calling me a uh like a [ __ ] you
know like they get called a [ __ ] like
thank you he realizes I'm a woman
yeah the word Kant is like it's not
appropriate except for this time it's it
is kind of welcoming it's kind of
Welcome like hey hey this guy's a dick I
guess but at least he sees me as a lady
I guess this [ __ ] is on the rag and
they're like thank you yeah yeah I feel
recognized I feel recognized that's a
good good good way to put it
yeah because you know I've obviously not
black but if you got called an inward
you're accepted yeah and you're you're
in even though that is a horrible word
much like [ __ ] you don't want to be
called a [ __ ] but if you're in that
position
it's the best you can ever hear
not the best thing but it's something
for sure you know it means like this guy
definitely thinks I'm a lady
yeah who I feel like inside yeah he's
like you [ __ ] you're like that means so
much to me yeah there we go all right
there's something there Louie had that
old bit uh buddy he grew up with this
guy who was like the meanest kid then he
transitioned and he tried to reach out
to the lady and she was mean to him and
he went he went he goes for you went
from a dick to a cut
that's Louie's butt that's solid yeah
yeah but all right I think there's
something here the n-word got maybe
we'll try I'll try tonight [ __ ] it well
watch Phil special on YouTube uh right
now please it's called Oola yes it's
killer killer great special time travel
bit is not in there so give it a check
great comic yeah can I plug San
Francisco please yeah you're an essay
yeah come see me in San Francisco from
the 5th to the eighth one of the best
clubs Diego as well coming up yeah San
Diego right yeah the 27th 28th 29th put
the best cities yes SF for me San
Francisco that's the first uh Molly was
the first person to like middle for me
to feature in America on American girl
yes and what great room to start in yes
and then the first uh headline Club to
headline me yeah amazing and I normally
play there the weekend before uh the
dead play Shoreline oh my God yeah so I
do the punch line and then I go to the
dead that's beautiful
magical we know San Francisco is I I
love it and Jim to me San Francisco
feels like half Vancouver half New York
City I could see that really do you see
that people argue with me no I lost the
weather SF is beautiful yeah the
airiness and the water but it's still
got the architecture yeah exactly you
could walk there yeah
good call that's a great week and SF
just a magical place one of the best
places.com we love you for supporting it
please watch my Netflix special same
time for them yes same time tomorrow
let's blow that up I'll be in uh Omaha
Phoenix Lexington New Brunswick OKC
Springfield Fort Wayne Indiana Happy
Thanksgiving to me some of the worst
cities
[Laughter]
like a televangelist run you know I'll
be in a tent and uh the road has risen
uh I'm in a San Jose Orlando Richmond
Iowa City Link in Minneapolis Portland
Oregon Seattle Washington Vancouver by
New Orleans Vogue theater you're doing
the [ __ ] with the boat theater you
know it of course I know all right
yeah Phil mottled there he was in a g
string Wilbur you're doing the Wilbur
Wilbur we're doing Sadies we're doing
the Fillmore we're doing uh something in
New Haven the Toronto the Blue Note in
Hawaii that'll be interesting whoa I'm
taking some wacky gigs folks yeah do it
up yeah yeah Wilbur's really wacky do it
for the story what are you thinking ah
well blue node that's a jazz club
that'll be that's just uh I want to go
to Honolulu yeah that's what the fans
want to hear
well they know how to lose good you guys
are the best we love you thanks for
listening ghetto whiskey subscribe to
the patreon we might be drunkpod
gmail.com email us send us packages at
251 West 39th Street nice we might be
drunk Phil the special's awesome thanks
for having me we love you you're one of
our best friends I love you guys thank
you for having me drink Bodega cat I'm
I'm not making any uh money off it but
God damn it's good I was shocked
appreciate it so yeah yeah check out
Phil special and apparently got an album
out there okay yeah please don't Chit
Chat while I'm pursuing my dream that's
that's old that's old but check out
please follow on YouTube Instagram fill
them handling Clips Great bits follow
Phil Phil M Hanley on Instagram follow
them on all the stuff uh YouTube Tick
Tock all that stuff we love you guys
thanks for listening comedy
[Music]
dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign